[Musique]
l'histoire du monde est l'histoire
de la violence l'
humanité semble déterminée à se détruire
mais il y a un artefact connu sous le nom de
pomme d'Eden avec lui toute impulsion
vers l'indépendance ou abelian sera
écrasée
nous avons retrouvé les protecteurs de l'
artefact  toutes les lignées sont
mortes sauf une qui
s'appelle Callum Lynch Je suis le docteur Sofia
RIKEN Je suis ici pour vous aider et vous êtes
ici pour me filmer comment allez-vous les gens nous sommes
là tout sur vous venez nous
cherchions quelque chose et  nous avons besoin que
vous l'obteniez pour nous
vous êtes sur le point d'entrer dans l'Animus ce que
vous allez voir entendre et ressentir ce sont
les souvenirs de votre ancêtre
mort depuis 500 ans qu'êtes-vous pour moi
votre passé attendez une minute
bienvenue dans  l'Inquisition espagnole
ce que j'ai vu là-
dedans c'était réel c'était
vous leur donnez la pomme et ils gagnent
les Templiers l'utiliseront pour nous détruire
mais maintenant pionnier et nous nous battons
et ils ont besoin d'aimer ça
[Musique]
tu es destiné à une grande célébrité  c'est
bon maintenant
nous travaillons dans le noir une sorte de délice nous
sommes des assassins qui fuient donc vimanam saver
2003 ma vie aussi j'ai une deuxième
saison de Kokomo en laisse Callum à distance Salinas
yo Santa Jack elle va faire des devoirs chez
Assad
Kalin était un vote judiciaire sur le
rapport de Casella poon existait voir  Kwazii - ah
sissie jamais poursuivre des publicités
[Musique]
Chris va pour l'apathie des électeurs libres
Buzzelli ohnfiddle tout superviseur des nouvelles
Lavoie Alton hey Hassan déchirer Sony
souvenir le Vuitton a dit jeu sur la
pré-vente salsa salut bébé Kevin tu n'es pas un
Kids Choice Benyard
Skoosh  si vous soulevez une idée par
ville au-delà de
lui-même, c'est que sur The Rocketeer
[Musique]
Kwami attaque sur les rivages où vous-même
qui êtes Eddie Sandow Lombardo
pour des céréales Hermès vous un
deuxième joueur génial
[Musique]